VERY SMART.
>> Tucker: I AGREE WITH YOU ON
THAT.
>> Sean: TUCKER, THANK YOU.
BUSY NIGHT TONIGHT.
THE CORRUPT, LYING, RAGE AND
HATE FILLED MEDIA MOB FLYING
AGAIN, SPENDING IN CIRCLES FOR
THE LAST 24 STRAIGHT HOURS,
THEY'VE BEEN ECHOING REPORT FROM
THE WASHINGTON
"THE WASHINGTON POST" CLAIMING
THIS UNKNOWN PERSON ON THE INTEL
COMMUNITY, ALLEGEDLY FILED A
WHISTLE-BLOWER COMPLAINT ABOUT A
PROMISE THAT TRUMP MADE TO A
WORLD LEADER ON THE PHONE.
DID HE PROMISE -- DID
PRESIDENT TRUMP PROMISED TO SEND
BILLIONS OF FREE FUEL AND
NUCLEAR INFRASTRUCTURE TO
NORTH KOREA?
NO -- WAIT A MINUTE, THAT'S WHAT
PRESIDENT BILL CLINTON DID.
DID HE PROMISED TO GIVE
150 BILLION IN CASH AND OTHER
CURRENCY TO THE MULLAHS OF IRAN?
NO, THAT WAS BARACK OBAMA.
DID YOU PROMISE TO BE MORE --
DON'T TELL THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
THAT I WILL BE MORE FLEXIBLE,
TELL MY BUDDY VLADIMIR.
THAT WAS PRESIDENT OBAMA TOO.
IT WAS ALL CAUGHT ON TAPE.
>> AFTER MY ELECTION, I HAVE
MORE FLEXIBILITY.
>> Sean: [IN RUSSIAN ACCENT]
I UNDERSTAND, I TRANSMIT
COMPROMISE MATERIALS --
OKAY, THAT'S HOW CRAZY THEY ALL
ARE.
LET'S RECAP HERE.
WE HAVE RACHEL MADDOW AS
AMERICA'S NUMBER ONE CYCLE
CONSPIRACY THEORISTS AND OUR
RUSH, RUSH, RUSH, CONCLUSION
THEY DON'T
REALLY SEEM TO CARE ABOUT
OBAMA'S PROMISE TO VLADIMIR OR
CLINTON'S PROMISE TO
NORTH KOREA, OR THE MONEY THEY
DUMPED ON THE MULLAHS IN IRAN,
BUT THEY WILL RUN WALL-TO-WALL
COVERAGE, AT THAT A NEBULA STORY
WHERE WE DO NOT KNOW THE
IDENTITY OF THE WHISTLE-BLOWER,
WE DON'T KNOW ANY DETAILS OF THE
ALLEGATIONS, WE DON'T KNOW WHICH
ALLEGATIONS, WE DON'T KNOW WHICW
ALLEGATIONS, WE DON'T KNOW WHICR
ALLEGATIONS, WE DON'T KNOW WHICD
ALLEGATIONS, WE DON'T KNOW WHICL
ALLEGATIONS, WE DON'T KNOW WHICA
ALLEGATIONS, WE DON'T KNOW WHICS
REFERENCE, WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE SO-CALLED PROMISE WAS.
NATURALLY, NOBODY ELSE IN THE
MEDIA THAT IS NOW ECHOING WHAT
"THE WASHINGTON POST" SAYS EVERY
DECIDED TO INDEPENDENTLY VERIFY
THESE UNKNOWN CLAIMS ON THEIR
OWN, THAT THIS UNKNOWN
INDIVIDUAL IS MAKING.
TONIGHT, "THE WASHINGTON POST"
IS ADDING TO THEIR UNKNOWN
REPORT.
AT THE WHISTLE-BLOWER'S
COMPLAINT, IT INVOLVES THE
COUNTRY OF UKRAINE.
I WAS HAPPY AT THIS NEWS.
MAYBE THEY WILL GIVE US
INFORMATION THAT THEY SAID THEY
WANT TO GIVE US, THAT WE HAVE
NOT TAKEN YET, ABOUT THEIR
INFLUENCE IN THE 2016 ELECTION
TO HELP HILLARY CLINTON, OR
MAYBE THEY ARE GOING TO TELL US,
OH, WHY THEY REALLY GAVE INTO
JOE BIDEN'S PRESSURE BASICALLY
LEVERAGING A BILLION OF OUR
TAXPAYER DOLLARS.
HERE'S WHAT WE ALSO KNOW.
WE KNOW THAT KEY FACTS, DETAILS
DON'T MATTER TO THIS MOB, THIS
MEDIA MOB.
RUSH LIMBAUGH POINTED OUT YOU
CAN TELL THESE PEOPLE ANYTHING
THEY WANT, THEY WILL REPORT IT
VERBATIM AS LONG AS IT CAN BE
USED TO SMEAR TRUMP.
GOES LIKE THIS, ONE NETWORK
REPORTS A SALACIOUS STORY, NO
STORY, NO SPECIFIC.
EVERY OUTLET, THEY WHIPPED UP
INTO A FRENZY, A CIRCULAR FIRING
SQUAD.
THIS NETWORK OF THEMSELVES ONLY.
THAT'S WHAT WE SAW TODAY, WHAT
IS A RAGE PSYCHOTIC LEVEL OF
SPECULATION, HYSTERIA, ON NEARLY
EVERY SINGLE SOLITARY NETWORK
OVER WHAT IS ONE, A CATCHY STORY
WITH NO DETAILS, NO SPECIFIC,
FROM BEZOS' "WASHINGTON POST"
HOUR AFTER HOUR, WHAT THE
EVENTUAL TRUMP HATERS IN THE
DEEP STATE WANTED, IT'S A
PATTERN.
AFTER ALL, THIS IS NOT THE FIRST
LEAK ON DONALD TRUMP FROM THE
INTEL COMMUNITY THAT WAS
DESIGNED TO SMEAR
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
REMEMBER, JUST A FEW DAYS AGO
WHEN THE MEDIA MOB WENT CRAZY ON
A REPORT THAT A HIGH LEVEL U.S.
SPY HAD TO BE EXTRACTED FROM
MOSCOW BECAUSE PRESIDENT TRUMP
COULDN'T BE TRUSTED WITH SECRET
INFORMATION?
THAT TURNED OUT TO BE MORE FAKE
NEWS.
THE SPY WAS EXTRACTED BECAUSE OF
REASONS UNRELATED AT ALL TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP THAT DATED BACK
TO THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION AND
THE REAL REASON WAS THE
EXTRACTION TURNED OUT TO BE
NOTHING TO DO WITH TRUMP.
NO.
THE OBSTRUCTION WAS DUE TO THE
MEDIA COVERAGE.
THEY PUT THE GUY'S LIFE IN
JEOPARDY.
AFTER THE STORY BREAK AND THE
GUY IS BACK HERE, THE MEDIA DID
EVERYTHING IN THE POWER TO
EXPOSE NOT ONLY THE PERSON'S
IDENTITY, BUT PRETTY MUCH GIVE
VLADIMIR PUTIN THE GUY'S HOME
ADDRESS WHICH WOULD BE A CLEAR
AND PRESENT DANGER TO HIM AND
HIS FAMILY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP DISMANTLES AND
EXPOSES THE DEEP STATE, THEY
WOULD DO NOTHING TO DESTROY HIS
PRESIDENCY.
HOW DID THEY GET THIS
INFORMATION?
LET'S NOT FORGET THE CHUCKLING
COMMENTS, THAT SENATOR FROM
NEW YORK TO CHUCKY SCHUMER IN
2017, YOU MESS WITH THE INTEL
COMMUNITY, THEY'VE GOT SIX WAYS
FROM SUNDAY TO GET BACK AT YOU.
REALLY?
THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE GOING TO DO
WITH THE POWERFUL POOLS OF
INTELLIGENCE THAT WE GIVE
THEM?
GET BACK AT US?
>> YOU TAKE ON THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY, THEY HAVE SIX WAYS
FROM SUNDAY GETTING BACK AT YOU.
EVEN FOR A PRACTICAL, SUPPOSEDLY
HARD-NOSED BUSINESSMAN, HE'S
BEING REALLY DUMB TO DO THIS.
>> Sean: THEY HAVE SIX WAYS
FROM SUNDAY TO GET BACK TO YOU.
WHAT ARE THEY GOING TO GIVE THE
MOST POWERFUL TOOLS OF
INTELLIGENCE TO PROTECT US AND
GOING TO TURN THAT WEAPONRY ON
US OR ANY PRESIDENT THEY DON'T
LIKE?
WE KNOW MEMBERS OF THE
INTERCOMMUNITY OF
PRESIDENT OBAMA, WE KNOW THEY
SPIED ON PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
ASSOCIATES AND, YES, HIS
CAMPAIGN AND TRANSITION THE
PRESIDENCY.
WE KNOW ABOUT THE INFORMANT AND
UNDERCOVER AGENTS, THE
OUTSOURCING OF INTELLIGENCE TO
OUR ALLIES TO CIRCUMVENT U.S.
LAWS WHILE WE ALSO KNOW THAT
THEY ARE NOT HAPPY THE
PRESIDENT, SOME OF THEM A VERY
SMALL MINORITY, EXPOSING THEIR
GROSS MISCONDUCT.
SO WITH EACH AND EVERY LEAK,
EACH AND EVERY SO CALLED BOMBS
REPORT SEEING A VERY PETTY
ATTEMPT AT REVENGE SIX WAY FROM